allez les schémas pression tu sèmes du
poste tout ce qui s'est passé à la télé
je vous pose des questions et on revient
dans à faire conclut qu est-ce qui
agissent sophie davant à pierre-jean
chalencon qui a créé une petite
polémique
c'est vraiment horrible chez vous vous
avez la même coupe que rené malleville
[Rires]
honnête et était très beau comme ça
vous estimez vous même vous appliquez
vous même ou à les faire danse avec les
stars
au lieu de dire des bêtises qu'est ce
qu'elle va nous expliquer ou même d'un
stick et vous vous appliquez le même
c'est bien gentil mais l'imam gens
regarder chez vous c'est parti bonjour
mon père mon régiment j'ai ma chérie
ceberio j'entends l'écho commence à se
tasser confinement j'ai pris cinq kilos
je lis les mémoires de guerre du général
de gaulle et je fais du ménage ja speak
to les objets que j'ai acheté d'affaires
conclut vous même vous estimez vous même
alors je vous laisse discuter avec bruno
allait remettre ça va zebar en séparant
ses parents alors depuis lundi france 2
diffuse une version confiné de son
programme à faire conclut et c'est vrai
qu'il ya énormément de gens qui se sont
moqués du programme je vous le dis
sophie davant accueille depuis chez elle
par écran interposé des vendeurs et des
acheteurs mais le programme n'a pas
vraiment été épargné par le figaro le
figaro ils les ont défoncé ils ont
publié hier un billet d'humeur intitulé
le monde d'avant dans lequel ils ont
décortiqué la première de cette nouvelle
formule de l'émission ils les ont
défoncé regarder petit récap alors que
certaines chaînes font le choix de la
rediffusion france 2 comme d'autres a
décidé d'adapter ses programmes en
version à la maison via un dispositif de
webcams l'émission d'enchères affaires
conclues a donc pu reprendre dans une
version lite qui n'a pas fait
l'unanimité une version numérique qui
perd forcément un peu de son rythme à
cause des décalages
[Musique]
et c'est le figaro qui s'en est pris à
l'émission avec un des briques pour le
moins charge le journal qui souligne lui
aussi les important décalage de son tout
cela est en direct mais légèrement
différée pour des raisons techniques
elle n'avait sans doute pas prévu un tel
décalage de sons et les longs silences
qui ponctue chacune de ses interventions
quand la technique n'empêche pas
carrément aux candidats d'entendre la
chose la plus importante le prix d'achat
de leur objet je vais vous en proposer
la somme de 700 euros
je ne sais pas combien ça fait des
problèmes techniques et des candidats
parfois mal à l'aise avec la caméra qui
ont rappelé aux journalistes du figaro
et soirée avec ses amis on dirait une
feinte d'apéro zoom trop arrosée vous
savez ces retrouvailles virtuel en passe
de devenir un rituel de nos vie cloîtrée
ça fait mal un constat que sophie davant
a visiblement fait elle aussi puisque en
fin d'émission elle s'excuse pour les
soucis techniques et promet que
l'émission va évoluer on affine le
concept pardonner nos ponts à l'estivé
pas technique mais on va s'améliorer
néanmoins les attaques de la part du
journaliste sont féroces alors on dirait
une feinte d'apéro zoom trop arrosée
comprenez vous les critiques du figaro
sur affaire conclue
alors est ce que vous comprenez les
critiques de ce billet d'humeur du
figaro qui a ainsi titré ça le monde
d'avancé françois aubel qui a écrit ça
après bon il ya des journalistes aussi
oui c'est du second degré aussi bien je
pense à un jean michel maire non je suis
désolé moi j'adore le figaro c'est mon
nom c'est une maison j'ai des journées
cela bas pendant des années des années
mais c'est vraiment un papier un peu de
pisse froid parce que s'ils pensent
donner un scoop en disant que quand on
fait une émission à la maison avec dans
le projet c'est quand même de rester
fidèle à son public
il faut une maison et une émission à la
maison avec les moyens du bord si c'est
pour dire que les problèmes techniques
oui les problèmes techniques enfin on
vit dans une époque envahi un moment
incroyable aussi dramatique
un nouveau dans les rapports humains et
cetera on crée un nouveau rapport à la
télévision aux voisins etc
elle a le mérite de continuer à
l'émission comme elle peut critiquer
schultz et bon petit chat ça va mieux je
trouve ça vraiment minable parce que les
chaînes de télévision franchement leur
tape souvent dessus en ce moment ils
font tout pour s est dit retire les gens
il faut rappeler qu'elle touche
quasiment pas un euro il n'y a pas de
rentrer de pub ltd millions tous les
mois elles font tout ce que notre canal
qui a offert gratuitement à des gens
pendant un mois et des animatrices comme
sophie davant
c'est pas évident de passer à la télé
comme ça on n'est pas très joli on n'est
pas ma qui est tout pour les femmes sont
encore plus compliquées
ils font tout pour respecter le
confinement et c'est de divertir les
gens ayant encore deux trois connards
pardon il encore il est encore un peu
tôt donc tant qu'à y aller il ya encore
deux trois mecs comme ça y'a pas
d'autres mots on venir taper dessus
taper dessus
on fait une émission en plateau
continent mais on a fait de chez vous
c'est la télé mais alors nous aussi nous
aussi encore nos amis bien entendu qu'il
faut pas aller voir un pure médias qui
nous sont notables de sucre
régulièrement tous les jours servir
c'est ce qu'ils font quand on fait des
records d'audience ils prennent vraiment
la tranche la plus faible ils disent
hanouna au plus bas dont qui twitte tout
ça ne rions pas césar examen garçon qui
a fustigé qu'avis boucher il est il est
exceptionnel qu'évident
alors voilà et je vais dire aujourd'hui
nous unit les audiences sont
exceptionnelles pour aider mission à la
maison sachez qu'on a
voilà on est très très heureux encore
yeux franck à pied tout à l'heure qui
m'a dit c'est incroyable le nombre de
gens qui nous regardent de chez toi
cyril avec le peu de moyens voilà qu'on
aille on essaie de vous divertir tous
les soirs et je vous dis c'est un
miracle il ya même la même je vous dis
le patron de la chaîne qui m'a dit
faudra peut-être gardé quelques idées
pour quand on reviendra en plateau parce
que l'émission commence vraiment
attrayant fonctionner il ya des bonnes
idées il ya des choses on en train de
recréer un access voilà une nouvelle
émission entre 18h et 21h et c'est vrai
que moi ça m'excite parce que tous les
jours je vois comment ça monte et c est
encore des journalistes qui n'ont pas
compris qu'on ne fait pas ça pour
l'audience
on fait ça vraiment nous voilà pour vous
accompagner tous les jours et il se
trouve que c'est vrai que ça marche de
mieux en mieux mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'ils doivent s'énerver et essayer
voilà deux parce que c'est vrai que je
vous dis que leurs médias ils sont très
pro et très haut voilà il faut quoi
qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment serré
lille vont continuer puisque mais
qu'elles ont compris que leur fond de
commerce alors donne et distribue une
incroyable sans toiture
c'est vrai parle de pure médias donc ils
vont ça toi tu parles après deux matches
ça va être pris que tu as parlé d'eux
ils vont être pas autant ils vont dire
bah après demain on va encore défoncé
syrie a dit oui mais les points
téléspectateurs ouais mais les
téléspectateurs sont pas fous ils fabre
connaît déjà sa lire ça de par les airs
dumars est de parler oui mais oui mais
ça on vous parlera jour sur la longueur
ils seront perdants je lui dis parce que
nous on sera ces jours là c'est clair
ils seront perdants parce que je pense
que il essaie de faire du clic parce que
malheureusement c'était compliqué pour
eux il a donc forcément ils essaient de
ce d'essayer de se voient la main de se
redorer la cerise sur mes lauriers de la
pub à l'oeil est exactement mais c'est
vrai aussi bon sur sur twitter voilà ils
mettent tous n'importe quoi voilà et
franchement ils nous font et et nous ils
nous font de la peine parce qu'ils sont
et ils se trompent de cible en fait
parce que nous il est très content et je
vous dis on est en train de recréer les
missions et raymond susurré connaît
c'est à dire que tous les jours on voit
ou acquiert plus en plus de gens mais
comme des fous tous les matins on se dit
c'est incroyablement cyril we made you
faut pas oublier aussi que toutes les
émissions qui en ce moment font de
l'info pardon c'est horrible ce que je
vais dire mais forcément elles sont un
tout petit peu avantagée par ce cas
heureusement en bas vous mettez vous ne
mettez juste coronavirus et tout le
monde en porte à faux bien sûr c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué en ce moment des
faits car des émissions de
divertissement de divertir les gens et
c'est ça le vrai challenge
on le voit d'ailleurs on le voit
d'ailleurs avec y'a que yahia n'oubliez
pas les paroles moi je ferai mon genou
et ça ça cartonne c'est génial pour
nagui mais c'est vrai que l'on voit les
fins a énormément de mal sur les
émissions de divertissement marois mais
voilà et lui tous les soirs c'est énorme
le nombre que vous êtes donc merci à
d'être aussi nombreux rené malleville
peut-être agir ou sur afer comprime sûr
que je suis une fanatique de à faire
conclut inconditionnels de sophie
lavables parce que la critique mais ces
défauts sont peut-être ces premières
qualités c'est une femme elle et elle
n'est pas parfaite mais son émission
mêlée comme la tienne tu paies des
niveaux et l après midi
elle fait des portes niveau qu'elle a
une audience extraordinaire jaloux des
bâches le site et au moins ils font des
efforts oui j'en dis oui honnêtement
c'est pas parce que tu adores nourrit du
tout mais est-ce que ça
est-ce que c'est pas une première
mondiale ce que tu es en train de faire
tous les soirs et sketches à l'histoire
de la télévision
une émission qui est fait comme ça avec
des gens à la maison et qui en direct
tous les soirs
alors franchement je suis blonde aussi
longue aussi long que je pense pas quand
on vois je pense que cela met en tout
cas voilà en tout cas nous je vous dis
on fait pas ça pour eux studio mont joli
ont fait ça parce qu'on kiffe su
retrouver mois mathieu il m'a appelé à
trois jours
il m'a dit franchement qu'est-ce que je
suis content mais ne rien d'être là tous
les soirs avec nous et ça m'a fait bien
plaisir
franchement et je vous dis on se régale
et je voulais et aurez vous rendez pas
compte
jamais on aurait cru faire plus d'un
million à un moment sur cette émission
vraiment jamais de la vie mais ça
continue à manquer oui bon ça c'est
horrible et ça ça occupe les gens mais
mais même nous pardon aussi ça nous
permet aussi de le temps de préparer
l'émission de se mettre dans son canapé
de sa rémission
même pour nous c'est formidable parce
que ça nous occupe aussi un peu au reste
de l'actu sinon comme tout le monde
restait ces soirées insert c'est
horrible donc on est content aussi
d'être ça mais aujourd'hui c'est juste
une petite affiche c'est passionnant
encore l'image de pierre jean salençon
venir sur ce que les gens pensent
peut-être que c'est l'émission sur fond
vert avec un décor c'est chez lui quoi
il habite à parier dans un palais le
palais vivienne des près de la bourse
selah sue holland centre de paris ça
valait napoléonien acte apporter un d un
bébé la db fidèle de napoléon
ça me paraît incroyable en dorures c'est
un endroit incroyable pari j'ai eu la
chance de discuter si vous avez ou si on
avait visité des choses oui tu sais tu
sais que je suis un fan d'affaires
conclut tu sais que quand je rentre du
boulot je me mets dans le canapé je
regarde j'adore cette émission
sauf que là moi je pense que le concept
ne convient pas à faire conclut ce
concept acquis fois moi j'aime bien les
avoir en plateau j'aime bien quand il se
passe l'argent tenez
par tout de suite avec son argent j'aime
bien le ping pong qui entre tout l'est m
moi je pense qu'ils vont c'est mon avis
je pense qu'ils vont pas pouvoir
continuer cette forme là parce qu'il est
difficile sauf si oui exactement
bravo et ils font des efforts bravo à la
production